you'd be Mrs Dutton I would  seems we're neighbors I've acquired the  Stratford Ranch  well this is the Yellowstone  and you have no rights here  Jacob you can't start a range War range  Wars already started  how much land do you want  I want the whole valley  either we take this fight to them or  it's coming us  men kill quick with a bullet or a noose  with their fight is with me  and I kill much slower  this is absolutely Wild  you're a hunter you're famous  tell the world what happens when they  cross me  greed will be the thing that kills us  all  the Rainwater  come with me  [Applause]  you attack my family it's gonna be the  last thing you ever do